[Music]
so you like to poo I love to poop yeah
yeah you feel like you're in a better
mood after you poop hi everyone I love
to answer okay you go first - TIFF just
looked at me sasa everyone
so Tim how do you like the food and
we're gonna go ahead and open the floor
to poop answers from all four members of
it yeah I I love pooping I I need to poo
before I leave the house or I just I I
feel uncomfortable at that's wonder you
have a regularly scheduled poop every
morning that's if I'm at home like all
day I'll probably [ __ ] like another like
three times
Wow you'd at the same times - roughly
roughly but if I poo in the morning if I
have breakfast I guarantee you have to
poo before I leave the house again
or I'll have to poo with like another
like hour yeah I've ever been
constipated for like an entire day I
don't remember the last time I went a
whole day without pooping unless I was
on like a long-ass flight and then not
good yes did not feel right inside yeah
exactly
so 90% of our service but I like poopy
[Laughter]
I'll just give you this back before I
get back to work I won't talk about my
poop - can I go after Steve let's go not
going to my favourite poops are the ones
when after you do it in your wife and
it's already clean you know like wow
those those are nice I like that but I
don't trust that I'm always like tonight
it's something I want one two three more
time it's me and then you start getting
blood on it that's - that's crazy you
burst in a hemorrhoid what some trusted
either
well you bust a burst it's again for
sure when that [ __ ] happens I go this is
how humanity is supposed to be because
we didn't have toilet paper as cave very
true you know that's me most of the time
really I never have any
I feel like you who pebbles though like
you're doing I think it's cute like it's
contains any bronze is the biggest
sheets in the game and we were never
give up sticks out of the water
she's sitting on top of it she looks
like well I was gonna well I was gonna
say a couple years ago I ate a whole
Papa John's Pizza I couldn't poop for
two days really you didn't get to pulls
on the pizza I feel sad yeah I felt said
that ate a whole pop I think I felt sad
that ate a whole Papa John's pizzas Papa
John's probably this is actually really
good it's pretty good but but it's way
too expensive and I'd like to eat the
deal expensive you like the Little
Caesars $5 pizzas no I like the Domino's
pizza that's the [ __ ] oh but if the Papa
John's paid me I would say the Papa
John's is the best hey anybody pays we
did a blind I did a blind pizza taste
video and and and I chose I chose Papa
John's out of all really I choose Pizza
Hut
really you can tell where's Peter though
that's my favorite the crust is yeah
yeah it's like that greasy has [ __ ]
pizza only this base we keep transition
from talking about [ __ ] food and like
seamless gross you guys are disgusting
and then back to poop so I mean Joe do
you tend to have some intestinal issues
yeah this is IBS hard yeah I got a BS
girl why do you think that other days
when you're more regular you feel
happier um it's like I'm on the view
yeah you said defensive - and then I've
IBS it is not proud
should define who I am [ __ ] that [ __ ]
you're a bad [ __ ] I don't let her
[ __ ] own me mi amore or am i on the
view well more is I know that's my poo
yeah
lie detector test says this is not your
poo I told you it wasn't my poo yes
around 90% of our serotonin is housed in
the gut so what they're saying is when
you have irregular bowel activity so
whether it's diarrhea or constipation
you actually it actually affects your
mental state in your act your emotions
you actually get depressed if you don't
have regular bowel movements there's a
new study that says that cortisol is
actually produced in the gut and not in
the brain really yeah yeah there's a new
series is that did you think with your
gut yeah which is [ __ ] great cause
the second brain and then they're saying
that probiotics are like the bacteria is
also what's manipulating a personality
really yes I wanted to ask you Steve
since uh since Nicky fixed her sea boat
have you noticed the difference in her
mood I have yeah she's not a big [ __ ]
anymore not a huge [ __ ] no yet she's
very um well she's always very present
when she's when she's having like an
emotional issue she always is like aware
of what's going on so she has an
out-of-body experience that can see
herself we could see what's happening
but she hasn't had as many of those
since she fixed her see both hmm that's
cool yeah that's interesting I mean cuz
like I feel like I'm a pretty happy
person and maybe now you guys got me
thinking it's because I like poop so
that's why I was asking about you
maybe you eat a lot of probiotics too
[ __ ] maybe I'm very positive gut
I try to be I try to be but I do when I
do get diarrhea on the rare occasion man
it's the I'm like do you get sad I don't
get sad I'm just pissed man [ __ ] the
socks maybe that's why I'm so angry I
get happy because I know that it means
I'm losing weight yeah oh I'm definitely
feeling myself out the day I'm in the
mayor taking pictures yeah that's not a
good way dr. bomber in any weight loss
though I wouldn't recommend that
I mean either it's
it's like instead of like eating an
eating disorder as a pooping disorder
yeah it's not fun
and then like I am really I like to
really make sure my my [ __ ] is really
clean so I when I have diarrhea
like I'm wiping it's like when you blow
your nose when you're take it and I rub
my nose in the toilet paper no you know
you blow your nose so much that it's
just like wrong hey I should get a bidet
you don't have one no I just you know
what I do if like if I don't have time
to shower afterwards and I and I'm done
pooping I just get in like two inches of
bath water and just wash my ass you
never had a man yeah if you had a
stomach flu you ever had a leaky ass to
where your stomach acid is burning your
[ __ ] bum hole crevice yeah and then
that's what happens after teen taco to
or like but if it happens too frequently
your [ __ ] hurts like crazy right so I
have to shower every single time I have
a stomach flu and I'm [ __ ] like
every 30 minutes
yeah dude and I'm like always taking a
shower cuz I have to marinate my [ __ ]
water just get one of those squeezy
bottles like the squeezy water box I
don't care about the environment I'm
thinking about - saving my ass like your
efforts because that's a lot of energy
you're exerting to shower every time I
just keep a bucket of ice and I use the
ice I put all my boho and cools it down
- you put ice on your butthole really
yeah you put the frigid frigid air this
guy's weird as [ __ ] no doubt but I don't
know if he's that weird have you been to
our bathroom you see the fridge on the
side mm-hmm there's a fridge on the side
ice cold water and it's [ __ ] ice cube
to rub brothers ass this is not a joke
this is real it's real life yeah ice on
your [ __ ] because it cools it down
what are you cools it down [ __ ] you talk
on the diarrhea from the diary Air Force
oh it's burning you need to cool it down
and then you're so upset and so this way
movies often this is happy quite a bit
we have every other week you have an ice
machine for your [ __ ]
you [ __ ] I think yeah I would like of a
day I need to get one for sure you know
what other thing I found out about the
whole gut bacteria thing so like
depending on what you eat that type of
bacteria that breaks down that food it
starts to grow in your belly right so
there are certain ones that make you
more angry or make you more sad or
whatever I don't know what the name of
the bacteria is so what they say here in
this article it says mood states have
been linked with the composition of the
mic microbiome
and mentally and physically healthy
adults so if your gut is unhappy it's
likely to affect your overall well-being
to both physically and mentally so they
don't say the exact one but they are
saying that there are hundreds of
trillions of microorganisms that form
part of the gut microbiome brain access
and it gets a addicted to it because
it's like a food source right so like
let's say that's how we get addicted to
junk food or all kinds of other things
because that bacteria that breaks down
that specific whatever it is like
protein and bread or whatever it takes
over your body it does and then when
it's hungry you get you get hangry cuz
then that kind of bacteria is like I
need more [ __ ] do this life that it's
like venom it is no venom takes over it
takes over and it makes you go do things
and when venom goes away look why did I
train [ __ ] Turtles you know you know I
love about our bodies though is that if
you eat some [ __ ] that's bad for you
you have poop karma like when you're on
the [ __ ] later you like take my poop
my first thought is oh [ __ ] what did i
do what did i eat to make this happen
you know I'm saying cuz I always I
always look to just to see like what
what what caused this current poop and
what what is what I hate now about
getting older is that when I was younger
I could eat all the spicy said I wanted
it would not affect my poo
but now something changed right where
it's like now you eat the spicy [ __ ] and
you're like this hurts me yeah the next
day so now I have to get the [ __ ]
Verde sauce so instead of the wrong hole
I know golf [ __ ] me up now the green to
matter yeah I ordered that for lunch and
I'm probably have diarrhea Jimmy do you
remember when we were maker that place
echo mine the Thai place and they had
that extra extra spicy oh yeah yeah you
get that I got that every time yeah yeah
yeah and it cleaned my whole [ __ ]
system out every time like damaging and
burning like people look in your
esophagus I'm not a [ __ ] scientist
and then you would take the post poo
mirror picture exactly what it feels
good what do you do I go get some
situational spices like next level it
numbs that's what I like about it do you
guys actually screaming a diary
I pray to God dude I I'm like I'll be
legit atheist at times of my life and
I'll go back to [ __ ] being religious
I'll be sitting there with holding the
handicapped barn I'll go from being a
[ __ ] hardcore Christian and if it's
not working I'm like Muhammad Tao God
give my [ __ ] relief confucius please
just afraid of mouth if it helps my
[ __ ]
[Music]